okay hello everybody welcome to another
NCBI minute today I'm going to talk
about the advanced search that's
available in DB gap this first slide is
just a reminder of a few housekeeping
details and things like that we're going
to make the recording of this webinar
available on our YouTube channel under
the webinars playlist there's a link
there to that YouTube channel ok so
today we're going to talk about an
advanced interface to GV gap so I'm
going to talk a little bit about what DB
gap is I assume that if you're attending
this webinar you probably know a lot
about it already but I just want to
introduce a little bit of information
about DB gap and then I'm going to show
you a couple of slides that show you the
interfaces that I'm going to be talking
about and then we'll go alive for a
demonstration of how to do this so DB
gap stands for the database of genotypes
and phenotypes and it contains human
phenotype data and related individual
level molecular data often these are
genotypes there are lots of different
kinds of studies in dbgap incumbency
lots of different numbers of
participants from you know a few to tens
of thousands there's about a million
individual people represented in DB gap
at this point across more than 600
studies EG app contains information
about the study's individual level
molecular data analysis results medical
images general information about the
study research protocols and
questionnaires molecular data types
include things like genotypes expression
level genomic sequence epigenomic
information somatic mutations that even
human microbiome information because
this contains human individual level
data there are privacy's issues and so
in order to get access to that data you
have to get controlled access
application and approval and there's a
document that's linked to the DDF home
page that talks about how you go about
doing that from the web point of view
the main way into DB gap is from the
stevie gap homepage which is easily
accessible from our home page the NCBI
homepage or from google or any search
engine that you like you just like the
DB gap in there and you'll get to this
page the main search box on this page is
basically an entree search interface and
you're probably familiar with those any
of our molecular databases have those in
PubMed in fact with an entree interface
what we have available now on DB gap is
a separate advanced search page that
makes it a little bit easier to find the
data you need it's sort of a better
adapted interface to working with DB gap
theta so if you click on that link
that's shown here on the DVF homepage
you'll go to that interface which is
really just an alternative way of
searching DB gap data on the web
climbing studies and other kinds of
things you need so basically this is a
fat what's of what we might call a
faceted search interface there are sort
of these filters on the right that what
you filter the studies their variables
the phenotype data sets documents
molecular data sets analyses by study
keyword search disease study design
alekhya your data type and marker sets
you can also do a keyword search across
all of these things all these different
aspects of the data while you're doing
that you're constructing your query
there's sort of an SQL type Corey that's
formed up there in the top and you can
adjust those by clicking on them to
remove them and there's a link there
that goes directly to this page if you
want it whatever I write links in these
webinar slides the NCBI thing in angle
brackets represents the NCBI homepage
URL ww ncbi nlm nih govt so what I want
to do now is leave the slides and take
you to this faceted search interface and
just do a couple of simple examples to
show you how it works so I'm going to
escape out a PowerPoint and I'm going to
switch over to my web browser and my web
browser is set right now on the NCBI
homepage and if you want to try to
follow along with me you certainly can
do that if you launch a web browser so
what I'm going to do is to get to the DB
gap homepage the quickest way to get to
our database home pages or one way to do
it anyway so just use this database
pulldown list and I'm going to select DB
gap and I'm going to click search so
here's the DB gap homepage and this is
where a lots of documentation is as I
said that information about controlled
access data is here if you want to learn
more about that or anything else that
you need to know about DB gap is
available here so I'm going to click now
on this advanced
search interface and that will take me
to the new search interface and there
are several tabs here study these
variables via type data sets documents
alekhya Datta states and analyses with
the numbers of all of these things that
are available for searching and then
over here I have a set of which you
might think of its filters with the
numbers of things that I can each one of
these aspects of things that I can
filter by i will use these to sort of
get a particular kind of data out of
here notice that the filters on the left
hand side change whenever i change this
first example if I click on variables
tab notice that there's now a new filter
over here I can filter by study so i can
select the study i want to fire i do
that likewise there are different
filters that are available further down
that pertain to that particular kind of
data for example if i go over here i'm
going to click on analyses notice of the
number of studies changes dramatically
there are 76 studies only the ab
analyses a variable available so we'll
see that happen when we do our searches
today when we go through the example so
what I want to do is start an example
with the studies tab selected and I'm
going to start out by thinking that I'm
interested in a particular human disease
and so I'm going to pick a particular
disease focus and I'm going to look at
type 2 diabetes so I can see what's
available simply by typing diabetes here
and i'm going to pick the check box here
that says they're 11 type 2 by v studies
so i can see them here and then there
might be other criteria that i want to
narrow this down by so one common thing
that you might want to do is to pay
attention to what kinds of consent is
required and this varies a lot depending
upon the particular study in some cases
you're restricted to doing research on a
particular topic the most general one is
general research use that's shown here
i'm going to pick a slightly more
restrictive one which means i need
general research use plus i need
institutional research board approval
I'll check that one and so I'm left with
a small set of two studies
actually I'm sorry there are three
studies actually one of them is a sort
of a parent of the other two this is a
fusion study the funeral in the United
States investigation of genetic study
and so I can pick one of these if I want
to learn more about it so if I'm
interested in sequence data and notice
that I could narrow this down if I
wanted to buy what kind of sequence data
what kind of data is available so i
could pick for example whole exome if I
wanted to I'm going to go ahead and just
look at this study is to show you what
you can get to from here so if I click
on the main link there it takes me into
the DB gap information about the study I
can see that it is a substudy of this
larger one and to get authorized access
that have to look at the larger study to
see what's required there there is some
public data public information available
on the ftp site the rest of it is
controlled access and i can read about
what it is this is looking at people
that have insulin insensitivity and so
basically you can see that they had
cases and controls and that whether they
are a case or control is based on some
glucose tolerance results and fasting
glucose levels and so we can go back and
actually take a look at the distribution
of those glucose levels if we want to by
using the facets to find that particular
variable so let me go back over here and
I'm going to add a keyword to this
I'll go ahead and add the keyword
glucose notice that as I construct my
quarry and I didn't point this out
before I have these little lozenges up
here these little graphics that show me
how the curry has been constructed now
notice that I'm really interested in you
know variables that are associated with
this what I want to do is click that tab
and now i can see that i have fasting
plasma glucose available and the two
hour glucose from my tolerance test here
so let me go ahead and click on the
variable page where the fasting plasma
glucose and so here I've got a nice
graph that shows me what the glucose
levels are for the people that are in
that case group these are the people
that are potentially a diabetic and in
the control group and then here is the
overall distribution of glucose levels
here that's a pretty quick way to find
out that kind of information I'm going
back to the facets page here now had I
visited that page by opening a new link
my previous search that I had would be
here and I would have to clear it get
results what I'm interested now is in a
totally different kind of variable I'm
going to be looking at something called
bilirubin which is a breakdown product
of hemoglobin that's in people's blood
streams and it's excreted in the bile
and some people are walking around with
fairly high levels of bilirubin in their
bloodstream so I'm going to look for
analyses that are about bilirubin so I'm
going to select that and I get eight and
they're from two studies one of them is
the Framingham cohort study which is
that longitudinal study that many people
are familiar with and then there's
another one that's kind of an
interesting one this is the National
Institute on Aging Sardinia study and
this is looking at a population of
people on Sardinia on the island of
Sardinia it's kind of a population
genetic studies when we go ahead and
select that one
so now I have two kinds of fractionated
bilirubin and total bilirubin and Hal
dozer these are going to be basically a
genome-wide Association results and so
this gives me a convenient link to the
genome browser so i'm going to show you
in a minute there's also a link here at
the fiji knee the phenotype genotype
integrator which is another really
useful tool for browsing and searching
for genome-wide Association results so
I'm going to go ahead and save some time
I've already loaded the genome browser
sometimes it takes a bit to load so I'm
going to go ahead and just show you what
that looks like so basically this gives
me a if I click the link it with load
and you can see this this gives me the
p-values basically of snips that are in
a particular position on the chromosome
and their association with a particular
trade in this case it's bilirubin if I
click here I will load the browser that
shows me the p-values of those
Association results here and there's a
cluster of them right here and there in
an ISIL linkage group here between these
two recombination rate Peaks here and
they all map to a particular gene
actually it's a complex locus this is
one of the blue Chronicle transferase
jeans its present on chromosome 2 this
is actually a complex locus with a bunch
of different products one that I'm
interested in they want to just show you
down here is ugt1a1 I can click to the
gene in the gene database and this is
the ugt1a1 polypeptide and you can read
about this that this is it's a it's
associated with could some conditions
that are associated with high bilirubin
one of them is called gilera syndrome
and that's a very common condition in
fact I actually have that condition so
this is just a demonstration of how to
use a faceted interface to find a couple
of different kinds of data and DB gap
let me go ahead and switch back to the
slides for a minute just to show you a
couple of other resources that are
useful when dealing with DB gap some
links to some
things so some additional tools what I
mentioned today was the phenotype
genotype integrator which is a good way
of looking at these Association results
like the ones we saw there at the end
there's also the dbgap data browser this
particular tool is relatively new and it
requires authorized access to to use it
for documentation as i mentioned much of
the DB gap help is linked right there to
the DB gap homepage but those are some
direct links to it and tau that's
created a bunch of fact sheets for NCBI
resources they're very useful I've got a
direct link there to the one on DB gap
reminder that we have a youtube channel
this video and a number of other ones
are available there there's a link there
to read me for all the fact sheets it's
kind of a nice index of finding them if
you have questions about NCBI resources
right to the helpdesk info at ncbi nlm
nih gov if you have questions about our
webinar program in other words
suggestions for what webinars you like
to see questions about the webinars
themselves right to that webinars
address and i'll make sure that
everybody gets a link to the recording
when it's available okay well if there
are no questions I'll go ahead and wrap
this up if you do have if you do have
any questions or think of any after the
webinar please feel free to write to us
the addresses are right there thanks for
coming and we'll see you next time
you